I was workin with that Wentz yeah, that Wentz yeah
But then his knee got bent yeah, got bent yeah
Brady's lookin' kind of old yeah, he's old yeah
So I guess it's time for Foles yeah
grease the poles yeah
Brady's hand got a stitch yeah, old as s--t yeah
lookin' like a b---h while we roll with Nick yeah
Lost our QB so we asked that backup
things looked bleak so we asked that backup
tried to say we’d fall when we asked that backup
But we’re gonna win it all, let's ask that backup
HEY CHIP IT'S YA BOY but NOT MARIOTA yeah
Cocky like Rocky, ask Minnesota yeah
Pats 'bout to get a curse like the Red Sox yeah
Girls love our D cuz of Long, Cox yeah
watch they all flirts, when I pass to Ertz yeah
Dunkin' tastes like dirt, Boston's about to hurt yeah
Brady after you snap, we rush through the slot
you’ll fumble-y wumble-y drop drop it like it's hot
Eagles D and we stoppin’ all your plots
See our defense is money like MAC jawn cash
Go to Wawa for a hoagie and an Eagles dog mask
Stop sayin' that our fans get ugly and rough
Come on, Philly is the City of Brotherly Love
Ask-ask that backup